[Musique]
l'apal du québec qui pose ou alors j'en
avais tu m'en faire vraiment conférence
de commencer cette conférence peut
déclencher un fort sentiment de partie
si ça arrive ça fonctionne elle ok alors
clavier fait des rencontres et des
départs tout commence à partir d'une
seule décision rester ou partir
telle est la question quand on prend
l'initiative
on dirait que notre monde se transforme
décidé nous redonne la confiance pour
prendre notre vie en charge de nouvelles
possibilités s'ouvrent et souvent on se
rend compte que nos rêves sont plus
claires plus proche qui avant les
découvertes des rêves tout arrive tous
les jours de mon histoire personnelle il
ya environ un an et demi j'ai pris des
décisions qui ont complètement changé ma
vie je me suis marié avec entrain chance
et québécois qui épargnent et vous
aujourd'hui
non et à cause de ça j'ai déménagé au
québec
alors au moment qu'il a rencontré
l'amour j'adorais voir mon pays
d'origine le brésil au cours des
derniers mois j'ai changé mon statut de
étrangère résidante permanente au canada
et j'ai découvert que les processus de
migration éveille notre condition d'être
humain
nos experts j'espère que j'ai bien
m'exprimer ici avec mes services mais on
expérimente les types d'émotions père
colère ont péri dans tristesse joie
affection bonheur il faut être
courageuse pour faire face aux menaces
de cette aventure imprévisible alors
regarde en arrière je me suis rendu
compte que mon processus d'émigration
est en effet une opportunité des
connaissances des moi même alors je vous
invite à faire partie de mon voyage
personnel avec trois stations d'arrêt
bouclez votre ceinture et venez avec moi
vous êtes prête houle station
détachement croyez moi il est possible
de possible de vivre avec moi j'entends
souvent des histoires incroyables des
migrants qui raconte je suis arrivé dans
ce pays avec une valise 10 $ de ma poche
et beaucoup de rêves et bien je suis
arrivé avec sept oui sept
cette valise plus en chine je suis une
femme j'ai besoin de voir des options
alors c'est ça que je pensais à 20
quitté mon pays
l'agapa rejet de laisser beaucoup plus
que de biens matériels au brésil
geminoid ma famille et mes amis c'est
vrai mais quand on décide de changer il
faut laisser quelques croyances
limitantes limitantes derrière nous je
vous donne quelques exemples qui en est
facile je ne suis pas capable
les autres sont mieux que moi je suis à
ma limite je ne peux pas faire confiance
à personne je suis sûr qu'ils certains
de ses pensées ont déjà traversé votre
esprit
la question est les avez vous cru la
paire la colère et la tristesse sans
sentiments fraikin est souvent présent à
cette station alors il faut vivre un
jour à la fois par contre
la curiosité l'espoir sont là aussi si
on croit qu'ils ce dont nous avons
vraiment besoin est déjà au rendez vous
ça rend la vie plus facile de les
schémas plus facile de continuer par
courrier citation un confort bon ce
n'est pas une station très populaire
c'est vrai qu'ici vais descendre dans
une situation inconfortable et peut-être
un athlètes d'endurance ne ramène
quelque sorte comme moi par exemple mais
ok normalement les personnes n'ont pas
vraiment les goûts de faire ça au québec
on apprend qu' ici t'es fait frette en
tabarouette je fais de mon mieux pour
bien exprimer un québécois
ça veut dire qu' il n'y a pas besoin de
confort ni thermique ni pyschologique je
vais utiliser les saisons de l'année les
quatre saisons de l'année comme façon
délivrer les messages de cette station
parce que la mère nature nous donne de
bons exemples de sagesse d'endurance et
de transformation est ce que quelqu'un
qui connaît cet endroit tellement
centène cet automne alors je suis arrivé
au québec dans l'été alors les stations
la la saison la plus extraverti de tout
j'ai bien profité des jours de soleil
les températures élevées des cours de
zumba entraîné à 7 et les fans puis
l'automne est venu avec la chute des
températures et ses nuances de jaune
rouge orange annonçant une transition
vers les rassemblements et pour la
première fois de ma vie je faisais
attention paysage qui m'entouraient cet
avantage de ralentir et de vivre présent
les verts à l'hiver à mon avis c'est une
saison où on doit être fort et la seule
façon d'être et fort et de faire face à
nos faiblesses c'est justement de
travailler nos faiblesses
dans mon cas la course à pied était mon
traitement de choc
littéralement parce que lorsque vous
commencez vous vous posez souvent la
question
voyons qu'est ce que je fais ici voyons
c'est bon signe mais après quoi
maintenant 5 5 8 minutes de course
vous vous sentez plus réchauffé et vos
niveaux les plus arrêté j'ai participé
du pantalon si c'était je pense le jour
le plus froid de l'hiver québécois lundi
passé or certaines et finalement les
printemps s'en vient la glace fond et il
veille toute la beauté cachée
après tout les autres à toutes les
adversités voilà l'histoire de notre vie
qu'il faut dépasser notre point de nom
et au 6è tapis rouge ici était ma zone
de confort je dirais que la magie de la
vie se passe au delà de ses limites et
heureusement malheureusement il n'ya pas
des ragots cible il faut tout surmonté
tous les livres côté tous les obstacles
finalement station appartenance sur les
stations la plus loin et ça prend un peu
plus de temps que ce qu'on pouvait
imaginer
et il est un des voyages varie selon les
besoins personnels alors comment savoir
si vous y arrivez
cinq ans nous nous sentons
reconnaissante de la vie comme n est des
endroits où nous sommes et c'est un
sentiment qui va x est très subjectif
mais ça veut dire qu'il vous est
finalement arrivé chez vous dans mon
voyage il ya eu des moments très
symbolique des mac communion avec la vie
qui m'a accueilli l'option des leaks
québec qui peut être plus motivant qui
recevoir un courriel qui disent c'est
vrai j'ai reçu un courriel qui faisait
votre sujet pertinent
votre idée est digne d'être partagée et
votre potentiel est excellent
honnêtement même si je n'avais pas été
choisi ce jour là m'a donné ma confiance
moi même les tadjiks québec m'a dit mon
premier wii et pour cela je serai
toujours reconnaissant les cibles
et ça c'est l'arrivée du marathon lévis
québec
j'adore courir le matin j'adore souffrir
d'une certaine façon
mais mais tous les québécois qui étaient
présents ce jour là à nous encourager
on fait pour moi plus plus que ce qu'ils
pouvaient imaginer
j'avais embarqué dans une aventure pour
découvrir notre version d moi-même et
leurs applaudissements étaient comme
l'acceptation finale dont j'avais besoin
alors si vous étés la merci alors
c'était très très important d'arriver et
on voit les bonheurs dans mon visage
même après 42 km de course
mais attention j'étais bien entraîné
n'essaye pas de faire ça sans
préparation qui va mourir pour te
rencontrer non c'est pas ça l'idée alors
ces jours là était la femme parfaite
dans cycle parce qu'une semaine avant
j'étais devenue résidence permanente au
canada et le lendemain j'ai commencé ma
vie professionnelle au québec
je travaille dans une entreprise qui
accueille fait confiance capacité des
immigrants nous sommes plus de 20
nationalités à travailler ensemble pour
une même mission
un monde plus vert à travers le logiciel
libre est là les technologies ouvertes
alors à la fin de mon voyage
ce n'était pas par hasard que je suis
arrivé à cette destination
comme dans les paroles d'une chanson
brésilienne qui s'appelle chez garda est
parti de chez gallimard chill sens
audoise leur dynamisme viage ça veut
dire que arrivée partir ne sont que des
côtés du même voyage après tout ma
réflexion
ma conclusion est qu'il nous sommes en
constant déplacement comme entraîne
quelquefois une façon plus lente
pourtant sans cesse les chargement varie
au long du parcours
ça peut être plus lourd quelquefois
d'autres fois plus léger mais c'est
correct on fait quelques pauses on a
juste la vitesse lyon continue
si on pense à l'échelle de notre
humanité
ça veut dire qu'on peut vraiment changer
le monde où nous vivons
tout commence par la décision de nous
changer nous mêmes les personnes qui
traversent nos vies nous apprennent
l'art de l'empathie
l'emportant se partagent la vie est
faite de rencontres et de départ tout
commence à partir d'une seule décision
sp ou partir quelle est ta décision
importe si vous êtes l'immigrant les
citoyens notre sens est identique et
elle s'appelle humanité alors pour
celles et celles qui veulent profiter
d'un voyage une aventure
d'épanouissement individuel avec une
contribution vers l'humanité je ne
souhaite qu'une seule chose
bon voyage il y aurait voir merci zen et
aussi me
merci